Everyone in the order knew Anakin Skywalker
few would live to see what he became
by the end of the Clone Wars.
I walked away from him and the Jedi.
Welcome back everyone
This is the way, there's a brand
new Ahsoka trailer, and they finally put
brand new footage
of Anakin Skywalker in the trailers.
Like they confirmed that he is going to be
in the series with new footage
They combined some old footage
with new voice over dialogs.
We'll explain the tricky way they include
new Anakin Skywalker in this. but.
I think the message that he's
giving to her sort of gives away
when this appears during the series.
of course I'll be doing episode videos
for when it starts in a couple of weeks.
Be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos.
I'll do a special giveaway
during my episode videos to.
So at the beginning of the trailer,
you see more of that footage of her
facing balloon scores character in him
talking about Anna-Kat
like more of the actual conversation
they have
as they start to fight around that Jedi's
star map on that same planet
there's a bunch of different lightsaber
fights happening on that planet.
So you have Sabine Wren versus Austin
hottie whose balance schools apprentice.
but while that fight is happening
in the background of that forest,
you actually see Ahsoka
fighting the inquisitor
Merak, who were all kind of wondering
who they're really meant to be.
I think the idea is that she defeats
the Merak Inquisitor character
and then she goes to fight Balan school
at the jury and star map
that's when he starts speechifying
about his history in the Jedi Order
with Anna and Skywalker
and how he knew who Ahsoka was because
of his conversations with And again,
so at the beginning of the trailer,
the extra dialog starts with him
talking about everybody in the Jedi Order,
knowing who Anakin Skywalker
was, but few living to see that he became
Darth Vader, like hoo.
He became
with the ending of Revenge of the Sith
because the whole idea is the battle in
school is meant to be a former Jedi
that survived Order 66 mean
that you survived and it can Skywalker
the way he's talking to her.
It doesn't sound like
he has a huge grudge against
what happened, but it does sound like he's
a little bit salty about it.
we always post the grogu meme.
I lived
but that's kind of the vibe
coming from balan school.
Like, I lived
Your master wasn't able to kill me,
They didn't say where he was when Order
66 went down, though I'm guessing
that he wasn't on course on they could.
Old footage of Anakin Skywalker and
Darth Vader on top of this conversation.
the footage of Anakin Skywalker
is from the Obi-Wan Kenobi series.
It's the flashback of them fighting
because he has his Padawan braid.
Remember?
Ahsoka became his apprentice
after he become a full Jedi knight
in the Clone Wars that actually started.
And he started to grow his hair out again.
Then we get the actual new Anakin
Skywalker footage, and it's actually
voiceover of him teaching Ahsoka
some lesson that he's giving her.
And I think that it's actually meant
to be the companion
to the scene of her training.
Sabine Wren on her ship,
is basically a scene of anarchy
and telling her about the coming Clone
Wars.
Like,
okay, things are going to be dangerous.
You're not always going to be fighting
droids as in the Droid army
because this is the Clone Wars
basically giving her a pep talk
as they get ready to go out on a mission
or he's trying to train her
the way that she's trying to train
Sabine Wren, you can do this.
I know you can do. This is okay.
So I think when we're getting
that voiceover, it's an actual flashback,
like the one we saw in the Obi-Wan
Kenobi series.
But I also kind of think that we'll see
force goes in again at some point,
maybe even later in the series.
kind of the way during the Obi-Wan Kenobi
series, we saw the flashbacks with the
Anakin Skywalker.
Then we saw present day Darth Vader,
and we saw present day
force goes quick on Jyn
at the end of the series.
so it's kind of the same vibe
with the way they include Anakin
Skywalker,
probably during the Ahsoka series,
like you see flashbacks to the Clone Wars
with a younger version of Ahsoka
getting ready to go out on missions
with the Anakin Skywalker
and him teaching her as his master,
as he calls himself as your master.
I won't be around always to teach you
during one of the previous trailers,
Rosario Dawson was actually recapping
Ahsoka story in like 30 seconds.
And there were a lot of people that had
questions about a couple of things.
She said she referred to Anakin
Skywalker as her Jedi master.
And she called herself,
she called Ahsoka a Jedi
during the Clone Wars episodes
and then during Star Wars Rebels.
She referred to herself
as not being a Jedi anymore
Enduring Revenge of the Sith Yoda
and the rest of the Jedi Council
allowed and again on the council.
But they very specifically did not
grant him the rank of actual Jedi master.
so when they use
the new Anakin Skywalker footage of him
referring to Ahsoka as her Jedi master
and his apprentice, and then Rosario
Dawson referring to herself as a Jedi
what I think is actually going on
is that Dave Filoni said that they did
change a couple things
about Star Wars rebels and the Clone Wars.
Like they retooled the continuity
just a tiny bit.
in the whole master
apprentice relationship between
Ahsoka in and again, just being the fact
that he was her teacher.
part of why I think Balan school
is having this conversation with her
about and again
Skywalker is to confound her
so that her mind is clouded and he can
actually beat her in the lightsaber fight.
but I also think what's going on
is this sort of that classic Star Wars
trope of the Dark Jedi or the darker Jedi
trying to bend someone
to his way of thinking every time he sees
a scene, even like Jedi Survivor in Jedi
Fallen Order,
when Cal Cast is runs into a dark Jedi
or someone who has turned into a dark
Jedi, they usually try to bend him
to their way of thinking.
Like, Look, my idea is way better.
Follow me instead.
one of the things that balance school
is doing during the series
I think is trying to pursue this new path
through the force
in the absence of the Jedi Order,
even though Luke Skywalker is in the midst
of trying to build his own brand new Jedi
Order, These two are meant to be similar
in that they both left the Jedi order
at some point, like after order 66,
he left the Jedi Order
and Ahsoka left by choice before order 66.
even though Ahsoka is not a dark
Jedi, obviously, and he is,
they're both doing similar things,
pursuing their own path through the force.
It's kind of what Grogu is doing
too, is the same vibe
He also chose to leave Luke Skywalker's
new Jedi Order.
We don't know a lot
about exactly what his plan is like.
Why is he working with Thrawn
and what does he get out of the equation?
Because I think that's going to be
a little bit different
from the original Thrawn trilogy
in the George Coppola storyline,
but he's sort of like the stand in
for that character in the books.
Dave Filoni said that
there would be some changes
from the original Thrawn storyline.
They're going to loosely
adapting the Thrawn trilogy for these
upcoming seasons of Ahsoka, as well as that
Thrawn movie Heir to the Empire.
One of the terms we use is,
you know, the war between the New Republic
and the Remnant empire.
So we're going to see, you know,
you need a conflict.
And I'm, you know, just kind of looking
at a lot of the things that were written
over the years in various
expanding universe projects, trying
not just to look at what John and I did,
but we're looking at what was done
kind of historically in the time
period is a guide,
there is a treasure of things to
to draw from,
not just within our own series,
but in the bigger galaxy.
there's a little bit of new footage
of Ahsoka with Sabine Wren and Huyang
in her ship
trying to fly away, I think, from Shin Hati
through all the different space whales.
the whole idea with the purgils
the space whales is they're meant
to signify the return of grand
Admiral Thrawn in Ezra Bridger as well.
People wondering where he is right now.
they're the things that actually took them
to the unknown regions because they can
navigate hyperspace just naturally
as part of their biological abilities.
did a huge arc for them during Star Wars
rebels earlier in the series.
So Ezra called them for help
at the very end.
They might also be part of the reason
why Thrawn was able to make it back,
but because the unknown regions
have been relatively mapped by the ships,
the whole idea
is that when they jump
to the unknown regions,
he probably had at least a loose idea
of where they were and how to get around
the way they've talked about his backstory
during the series, like this missing
time period in the original trilogy
when he was lost in the unknown regions.
That is where he found
his new fleet of ships that you see here.
I talked about this in my previous video.
these look way more ornate, like
they could be from the High Republic era.
but I think they're meant to be kind of
like the stand in for the katana
fleet in the original Thrawn trilogy,
like this missing fleet of ships
that are really powerful
and give him the edge in the battle
against the New Republic.
part of the way
I think they plotted this out
is that they find Thrawn
actually coming back.
He actually shows up with his fleet
of ships by the end of the series.
Everybody's like, Oh no, we're screwed.
The New Republic was wrong.
He really is back
because it seems like Mon Mothma
and the rest of the New Republic Senate
don't actually believe Hera in Ahsoka
they kind of gave that vibe during the
Mandalorian series, like The New Republic.
We're making
just the same kind of mistakes
that the Empire was getting bogged down
in a lot of bureaucracy in ripe
for someone else, like a group of rebels
themselves the Thrawn
and the Shadow Council are now
acting like to come in and take over day.
Filoni talked a lot about this,
about how the Imperial Remnant is
acting more like the rebels were
before the original trilogy.
At this point.
so the themes of The New Republic
has been acting really badly, really dumb
during the last couple of seasons.
The Mandalorian That's on purpose.
They want to explain why it was Ron was
able to come in and almost overthrow them
now we just need footage of Grogu
The Mandalorian, one of the trailers,
and some of the other Mandalorians
like Bo-Katan in the Mandalorian Tribes
on Mandalore then they'll actually cover
the war itself.
The war will begin
during the Thrawn movie, kind
of the way they began Revenge of the Sith
with that giant space battle over course.
On they'll probably be a couple
more trailers before episode one begins.
But remember, they're dropping episode
one in episode two at the same time.
So we'll just do separate videos
for both of those episodes,
but then they'll just go to one episode
per week, like Normal on The Mandalorian.
there's a whole bunch of stuff coming up.
Cannot wait to see some of
the big surprises they have on the series.
So if you have any questions
about what's going on
or you spotted anything
in the trailer footage for this
in a can trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video,
write it below in the comments.
click here for all my other Ahsoka videos
and click here for my brand
new Loki Season two trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe.
And this is the way!